des canadiens consomment de moins en
moins de boeuf poulet porc et poissons
de moins en moins de protéines animales
c'est ce que nous apprend une étude
réalisée par l'université dalhousie
sylvain charlebois et directeur de
l'étude professeur en distribution
agroalimentaire il était à halifax
bonsoir sylvain charlebois bonsoir alors
pourquoi les consommateurs consomment de
moins en moins de protéines animales
il ya cinq facteurs qu'on que nous on a
évalué d'abord l'environnement
vous savez 18 % des gaz à effet de serre
en fait émane de l'agriculture et de la
production animale
il ya le bien-être animal aussi qui
fatiguent beaucoup juin c'est ainsi il
ya le prix aussi qu'on a regardé la
santé et le goût est ce qu'on s'est
aperçu avec les résultats c'est que
c'est la santé qui qui dérange le plus
qui incite les consommateurs à réfléchir
sur la relation qu'ils ont avec avec la
protéine animale de pression au général
et avec le boeuf surtout c'est le boeuf
qui est ciblé parce que pour la
production de boeuf on parle de beaucoup
de ressources et il ya beaucoup d'études
qui démontre que justement trop de
consommation de boeuf peut être prête en
fait moi ap la santé et donc les excuse
est ce qu'on peut dire que l'industrie
du boeuf en redressant déjà les effets à
mon dieu oui si vous regardez la demande
annuelle de 2010 est au canada
et si vous comparez cette demande laudun
en termes de volume par rapport à 2010
la demande
boeuf au canada a chuté de 94 millions
de kilos annuellement en huit ans donc
c'est énorme et c'est certain que les
que les producteurs bovins en fait eux
ressentent mouvement le saas est ce
c'est clair j'ai rencontré jean les
rencontres plusieurs d'ailleurs en
alberta à sa main et on se questionne
les guide alimentaire qui indique sans
vient aussi qui va probalement justement
encourager des gens de consommer des
protéines végétales aussi donc il ya une
inquiétude qui est palpable au sein de
la fia bob et est ce que il ya une
question de génération aussi dans ça
parce que on dit souvent que les jeunes
qui on le remarque d'ailleurs sont
peut-être plus sensible aux défis
environnementaux que représente la
consommation de viande taux est
absolument haut niveau lorsqu'on évalue
les générations où l'effet des
générations il ya deux scénarios qui se
présente d'abord il ya les jeunes la
génération z éliminer nos yeux arrivent
avec un bagage de valeur qui contraste
un peu avec les boomers par exemple on
veut non seulement acheter de la viande
on va on va on va adopter la viande on
va on va tenter de retrouver les valeurs
qui qui qui nous interpelle chez les
jeunes alors avec l'environnement la
santé et le bien être animal de plus en
plus un malaise et c'est pour ça que la
majorité des vegan et des végétariens
ont 38 ans ou moins
à wil ouais c'est énorme et c'est pour
ça que le chiffre de 6.4 millions qui
est véhiculé aujourd'hui c'est difficile
de voir comment ce chef d'oeuvre diminue
en raison du fait que la majorité des
dévs egan et des végétariens ont 38 ans
au moins l'autre scénario c'est les
boomers c'est le flexitarisme donc les
gens qui veulent être végétarien ou
vegan à temps partiel les boomers dont
pâtissent pas la moitié des flexitariens
sont des boomers intéressant est ce que
des différences aussi entre les hommes
et les femmes mais selon les âges dont
vous avez 10 38 ans l'homme et quelles
sont les différences de ce côté là
homme peu prévisibles les hommes aiment
la bière à consommer de la viande a
toujours été perçu comme un geste
masculin et sa part être viril
ouais c'est ça avec le barbecue tout
alors vraiment il ya un attachement
assez particulier chez les hommes et
chez les femmes il ya l'attachement mais
pas aussi fort et aussi ce qui est
différent c'est que les femmes vont
avoir plus de facilité à reconnaître les
alternatives de protéines donc on va
reconnaître les lentilles les pois
chiches le poisson le le tofu on
reconnaît qu un portfolio de ressources
pour remplacer la viande dans ce que
l'homme bon viendra qui veulent
remplacer de la viande mais avec quoi on
sut proto et qui réduit dans les
provinces sa consommation de protéines
animales de plus bas d'abord le québec
est dans la moyenne
il n'y a pas vraiment de surprise la
masse et l'ontario et la
colombie-britannique particulièrement là
où vraiment il ya en fait on des laisse
tranquillement pas vite la viande dans
le cadre dr yo moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on que c'est en raison du
multiculturalisme et beaucoup de gens
qui arrivent de l'extérieur du pays où
la consommation vient il faut l'avouer
est un luxe c'est un luxe partout dans
le monde
au canada on est un peu choyé et encore
britannique est un écosystème de valeur
alimentaire qui est particulier encore
botanique et c'est peut-être pour ça que
plus de vue citoyen de végéta et qu'à
moyen et doit s'arrêter ici sylvain
charlebois c'est intéressant on va se
reparler prochainement parce que le
nouveau guide alimentaire s'en vient
bientôt
merci beaucoup sylvain charlebois convoi